please welcome to the stage Hans came
love gangsters it's good to be here and
there are a lot of white people here
which this surprised me this place is
called Kirkland maybe the Kirk's son
called Chang ville cultural town I'm
just kidding I knew this places way
because i live in juanita from here but
it dress me highly you know might be
awkward on the local QSC and you're the
one that crush my dreams added incentive
I love doing comedy I love coming to
comedy show us because you meet some of
the interesting people i met a landscape
painter once and we were in conversation
he said Hans I could never do what you
do what you do is so brave and I was
like sir when you're right you're right
you're a coward who hides behind his
easels cuz i think painting would be a
lot more difficult if you're painting
your picture and your canvas was like
boo
that doesn't look like a treat you
should quit drawn something Asian some
canvas is a racist is going to be here I
am single and I've yet to find my soul
mate I'm beginning to think maybe it's
her fault she's get out more she seems
like a loser I think I can do better
thank you my friends are always my
people always say hey hon do you just
have a hard time talking to girls you
just feel learn how to talk to girls
maybe maybe girls have a hard time
listening to Hans why don't you want to
hear about the Federal Reserve it's
interesting lot of numbers I love women
I think they got the best pair of
genitalia and the human race definitely
in the top two we got ladies and I think
I think women are important because men
can't your birth and even if we could we
would be the worst end of it we're
always in the gym trying to get
conference will we be like bro I baby so
much protein and creatine during my
pregnancy baby's like 20 pounds already
pursued it my friends try to make me
feel better about dating my friends like
dude at least you're not gay if you're
gay that means most of the gender that
you're attracted to is it attracted to
you back and I was like oh man can't
even imagine they must cry a lot I'm
crying I met a girl who says she's into
asian guys which is kind of worrisome
because there's like a billion of us
where the most easily replaceable fetish
I gotta be on my aging like hey ma
english rice sexy is that turn you on
that I respect my ancestors I am asian
or is unknown this country in Chinese
I'm from Province in China called South
Korea favorite it's right next to the
Japan province
a lot of my friends and hurtful things
to me growing up my friends were always
like hey Hans you're not such an Asian
smile I was like thanks now I get to
think about how I'm physically different
from everyone around me every time I
feel happiness that's what girls my
sister just got back from a mission trip
if you don't know what that is a mission
trip is when Americans go to third world
countries to get new profile pictures
like a photo shoot this princess I think
it's funny that tanner is a white
person's name
tanner than what it should be like hey
this is my Mexican friend tanner this is
my black friend tannest I love living
here in kirkland but something I'm not a
fan of are they express toll lanes or
whatever yeah right because I'm pretty
poor and life is pretty stressful when
it can be financially devastated by
changing lanes it's like 75 cents oh no
no pencils this funny I'm not a fan of
carpool lanes in general because I don't
need any more incentives to not be
lonely carpool lanes is like society
saying hey Hans you know how you're
lonely yeah do it for longer than take
the long way home really think about
watch watch people with friends whizzing
by you hey fun that's what I thank you
guys so much say madam and show his
friend